if you find yourself always running
toward the walking dead
here are five other titles worth
checking out on this week's
binge guide amc's hit zombie show has
officially been around for a decade
and along with two spin-off shows the
walking dead has brought us all kinds of
dramatic moments and plenty of walkers
over 10 straight fresh seasons and
hopefully this list will be a great fit
for your next few binge sessions like
ragged clothing on a zombie
starting with our certified fresh pick
ash vs evil
dead with three seasons all coming in at
98 percent or better this show is about
a chainsaw-handed 30-something who
reluctantly becomes mankind's only hope
against a deadly plague
the show co-created by sam raimi is a
sequel to his certified fresh evil dead
films from the 1980s
and critics say the show stays true to
the movies with grisly
action-packed thrills and laughs you can
binge both evil dead movies and all
three seasons
in about 18 hours and i won't blame you
if you want to replace your hand with a
chainsaw afterwards
our editor's pick this week is the fx
show the strain
this show is co-created and based on a
book by famed filmmaker guillermo del
toro
about a viral outbreak with an evil
strain of vampirism
that ravages new york city critics say
the strain has an effective mix of
supernatural thrills and b-movie gore
while its political and philosophical
subtext add necessary heft
for adult viewers you can binge the show
in about 33
hours but you probably shouldn't watch
it while traveling to the big apple
howling its way in as our brand new pick
this week is
raised by wolves this recently released
hbo max show with the certified fresh
first
season is from executive producer ridley
scott and centers on two androids tasked
with raising human children
on a mysterious virgin planet critics
say this sci-fi fantasy is bristling
with imagination and otherworldly
imagery
that will stimulate the eye and mind if
not the heart
you can binge the first season in just
under eight and a half hours but don't
expect to see anybody being raised by
actual wolves ruling our audience pick
is the period zombie thriller
kingdom with two fresh seasons this
netflix show follows a korean prince
sent on a mission to investigate an
outbreak that threatens his land
based on a web comic series called the
kingdom of gods critics call this series
a refreshing addition to the zombie
landscape
with its enthralling blend of blood
terror and political intrigue
you can binge the first two seasons in
right around nine hours
and you can do it from the comfort of
your own kingdom you know on your couch
in your underwear and finally our under
the radar pick this week is the bbc
series
in the flesh with two fresh or should i
say
flesh seasons this show follows an 18
year old zombie who has been
rehabilitated by the government and
returned to live with his small town
family
unfortunately canceled after two seasons
for budget reasons
critics say this show actually exists
within several genres
growing into profound entertainment that
haunts as it entertains
you can binge online episodes of this
show in about eight and a half hours
and then you'll be well educated for
when a zombie rehabilitation bill
appears on the next ballot
okay hopefully this list will take a
bite out of your next few binge
sessions let us know in the comments
what you're currently streaming
and be sure to check out the new rotten
tomatoes is wrong
a podcast from raw tomatoes because
fresh and rotten
is just the beginning of the
conversation new episodes drop
every thursday and if you don't want to
miss out on any future recommendations
based on the shows and movies you love
make sure you hit that notification bell
and subscribe button
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next vid
you